um less than me
um yeah yeah significantly Nationals
anymore he would still be my man
probably it doesn't really matter to me
I love the person for the person if it
stopped me from doing things and living
the life that I wanted to live then I'm
not with the right person like if I love
someone I love them for them I'm not
really materialistic about stuff like
that is there a minimum
what figure yeah I mean because yeah to
be honest let's be honest because he's
unemployed if he's unemployed for two
years you're out yeah probably and I
hope you would be yeah he's unemployed
for two years I'm out but so there has
to be like a minimum what would you
roughly say it is
I couldn't I don't know what people earn
and not shift work I couldn't tell you
how much you'd like him to bring out my
movie not shift work like what would you
like him to bring I'm a month yeah in a
month two grand three grand
four grand
remember you you listen if he says quit
whatever the amount that sustains us to
like be happy but I don't need like big
fleshy things to be happy if you'd be
happy living in the Caravan
there's someone there's there's like a
couple people in these boxes over there
oh yeah down there in it yeah
they've got this box set in the roads
I've seen that I don't think I could but
money doesn't determine like the person
for me if that makes sense
I don't know if that answers your
question I no I don't know
there's no minimum like come on no
minimum I don't know things like that I
don't know what people earn for you what
like to have all your Necessities met
um
do you mind your own yeah I live online
okay so you know what it takes to
sustain you yeah do you want him to be a
provider basically because if you do you
know you have to know your minimum
surely surely unless you don't mind
providing for yourself then it doesn't
matter at all
yeah can we not come together was that
not an option
is earning less than me yeah so I I'm
I'm saying at what point do you respect
his decision making
so like if he said quit your job
tomorrow I have a plan I'll listen but
if he's a bum and hasn't worked in two
years why the hell would you do that
yeah I would definitely not listen so so
there's a minimum point right yeah
there's a minimum point where and it
doesn't have to be exact you know just
just a rough figure where you would
listen to what he says
I want to see I couldn't tell you I
couldn't tell you a figure okay what
about 30 30 000 pounds would you listen
is that the minimum people just go off
like what it takes to sustain yourself
and then could you live on a thousand
pound a month if he's bringing in like
between three and four thousand three
and four thousand I think yeah that's
fine a year no a month a month oh yeah
that's nice that's fine it's modern nice
or something I like it yeah okay
um what about you would you date a guy
that makes less than you I would date a
guy that
um
yeah I would but he would have to be
able to like pay the bills what's your
what's your minimum
um I would say for Grand because that's
like enough to like pay bills rent or
mortgage
um can't know that sort of stuff okay
what about you
[Music]
um
I think I would respect him
I don't believe you why don't you
believe me
um oh gosh what's your minimum okay my
minimum
I'll be comfortable with let's say 3K a
month I think that's Friday okay to
bring in
um I think it's all down to I don't know
if it kind of relates to the question
that you're asking I think it's just all
down to ambition if he's a bum no she
said no no that's what he's gonna say
this is the problem with women she said
that's who's gonna happen it's gonna be
a hiring or one day no he's not
he's happy at his job he loves it he
loves it it's not it doesn't mean he's
lazy maybe he's like a I don't know do
police officers yeah Postman do police
officers
yeah yeah oh God I mean I worked out my
jobs it's all right
I think my Approach generally is a job
is a job as long as it's keep making you
comfortable then I will respect that
full stop yeah I think that's just it oh
yeah but I mean in terms of like respect
I mean if we're living together and we
have a family and I meant to like
respect all your decision making
if you're not earning at least to cover
what it takes I mean it's like okay if
you're dating a guy that makes 250 000 a
year pounds or whatever it is here
um if he says quit when
I get yeah that's so much money it's
when like when do you want me to but at
some point like it switches to where you
give him more control
because if a bum tells you to do that
you're not going to do it yeah if it
hasn't worked in two years he says quit
you're like what I can all agree on that
though yeah which we all agree on but
like I'm just asking roughly around what
point is it that you respect his
decision making
like roughly four grand a month okay
that's a good question are these are
things that you wouldn't even ask
yourself oh yes I'm actually kind of
glad that I'm here I think if you want
to get married you kind of have to do
them yeah like because it also depends
how many kids you want yeah so like how
much does each kid cost yeah you need to
think about these things while entering
a relationship especially if you're
going to merge into one I feel like
women do don't they yeah like even on
first dates exactly like what would our
wedding look like yeah
what area are we gonna move to and the
man is just right there looking at the
stage yeah but we're at five years into
it she's like oh today's a nice day
she's like we could have two kids
the white picket fence is there yeah you
think about that career ladder as well
all of it yeah 100 and you look on
glasses I think women like for fantasize
a lot oh yeah and think way into the
future that's good because that's how
they help men like Blossom like that's
how women are health system in because
men are very like and women are like oh
but you could do it this way and this
way and like they flower the seeds that
make it grow women have to like think
outside the box because men are very a
matter of fact which is good and that's
why the woman and the man works together
yeah yeah it's like that quote
that's I think it says something like um
behind every great man is an even better
woman or something Have you heard that
one yeah oh yeah that that's the most
quote I don't think it should
be even better but I think great women
should be there instead but it kind of
oh just the woman that cares yeah yeah
this is woman just because every man is
this woman his woman Elon Musk needed a
woman to get to where he's at Richmond
get to where they're going regardless of
whether or not they have a girlfriend
dog eat dog for sure it's like I mean
like the guys that are going somewhere
they're gonna go somewhere whether or
not you're there it's just like women
just like to take credit for doing
nothing yeah
I guess I listen I think unless you're
looking at having kids men can just
pretty much
do anything whereas they don't need
emotional support well they do yeah they
don't need it as much as women like I
don't think they need it like women like
to talk about stuff more they're with
their friends what do they talk about
talk about guys talk about feelings talk
about look men are just like straight to
the point we we're gonna round a bit
more but it works together
um
I like the chorus yeah
and they're not even do you're not even
doing it this time you've got a whole
chorus here
they always roast me in the comments
obviously they're laughing because I
think normally it's Pearl and every
woman is doing it I've been trying to
get better I've been trying nothing
about these interview I've been trying
it's like it's a tick I can't no it's
just a thing in it because all the women
are doing it one person made a comment
and I'm just saying listen to the choir
and the choir said
I love that Auntie oh what do you think
I've never been out of a man that's a
more than me never never
and I've respected every single one
um
why do you think that is different than
a lot of women nowadays
I just don't really care how much I am
because no
it didn't really matter is that when I'm
out of a man he's a man
so I don't
I don't pay for anything I'd have to put
my hand in my pocket even the man that
I've got now
let's talk about more than him he's got
my I'm asking about he's got more cash
to me I've got more assets than me
but no I can't I'd have to put my hand
in my pocket for nothing yeah I think as
long as I don't have to put my hand in
my pocket then yeah I have no problem
what is what is the minimum
person Panama if I can make it work you
know our camper oh oh you know I can
make it
so if these people if these women are
here are saying oh they need to do this
oh the man can't afford that you know
what I mean check yourself and come back
do with a thousand pounds a month how
would you spot that up I'm just curious
I've got wholesalers yeah I mean it's
different because all right then if I
had a movie you live in London with a
thousand pounds a month I can live in
before I was living I can do it on 1500
okay because like 500 is towards the
mortgage yeah kids are not expensive it
all depends do you know what right it
all depends on what you want them to
wear but nowadays you'll find that
a five pound t-shirt is not gonna cost
you 50 pounds for the kid or because of
the name or the stamp on it and that's
what brings things up or you know eating
out you know you want a burger buy some
mince meat and teach your kids how to
make a burger
you know no eating out
no do you think a thousand pound is
covering bills it's still me now
wow you know I honestly had the same I
had the same thought yo she took me she
took me how much did you say was 35
pounds it was 30 pounds 30 pounds 30
pounds she said 10 a week yeah for two
people yeah she told me she could get a
week's worth of groceries on 30 pounds I
didn't believe her and go to the market
yeah she took me she took me no we went
to the supermarket we didn't even go to
a market yeah you can do it you just
yeah we'll talk on Fresh stuff is this
10 yes or no no it was actually good
food check out wave School episode two
okay School episode two but yeah I I
didn't believe her I was like there is
no way there is no way but yeah 30
pounds you have to look for the stickers
the clearance stickers
in the morning we just went in there we
just we just popped in there and we
picked about four things with stickers
but everything else wasn't was it it was
about four things of stickers in the
middle of the day yeah now in Eve was it
in the evening
but it wasn't bad food it really wasn't
right yeah but you have to even though
this month to cover a whole month
including toiletries laundry alcohol and
everything for the month a thousand
pounds
yeah for the month I'm talking about all
the alcohol as well or laundry
toiletries electric toothbrush
everything Frozen pan then that's it
yeah I'm gonna watch it I'm sold it's
fine I'll show I show you my tricks yeah
I'm sorry I need a few tips as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible